high-fructose corn syrup is the new
supergroup coca-cola the world's largest
average maker has been secretly working
with bloggers around the globe to spread
its message that coke can be a healthy
treat and the company isn't just working
with any old bloggers there specifically
paying nutritionist and fitness experts
to suggest their readers that a can of
coke can be good for you a coca-cola
spokesperson told The Associated Press
every big brand works with bloggers and
has paid Talent considering soda sales
have plummeted nearly 20 percent over
the last 16 years coke may be willing to
invest a lot of money in their own
personal blogging army all right so I
would be remiss if I didn't start with
this it's one of my favorite talking
points in our coca-cola here in America
and in most of our sodas we don't use
real sugar we use high fructose corn
syrup because they figured out a way to
make corn sweeter than sugar and it's
cheaper so you have to get a Mexican
Coke taste so much better too to get
real sugar drink and it actually tastes
better so that that's a sidebar to this
but people really need to understand
that that that's what these companies
are doing they're not even giving us
real sugar not that sugar is good for
you we're making corn into something
sweet so this story sounds like the coke
people are in cahoots with the drought
people because they want you to drink
more coke less water uh uh the drought
people from before we're gonna edit 8:00
to that no you're good shouldn't [ __ ]
like this I'm not for over legal uh over
controlling everything but shouldn't
[ __ ] like this be illegal coke funding
these things to somehow trick people
into thinking that that is if there's an
insane amount of sugar in there everyone
knows what kind of crappy dietician or
or fitness instructor or you if you're
recommending coke in any capacity but
can't you get anyone to do anything you
can pay someone enough money they'll say
anything right gimme yes this is correct
how much you pay me say you did that
well yeah coke is terrible for us right
and we drink soda I do not drink soda
pop no I just stop drinking soda a long
time ago it's a lot of bad things not
only the sugar but even if you go non
sugar Massa déjame the acid is bad for
your teeth and your bones and stuff like
that and so it's not good for you at all
anywhere around aspartame Co you know
creates tumors so I'm not supposed to
say that cuz that's not medically proven
but I'll say it yeah well you're not
science magician you're just the guys
saying you're some uh comedians about
yeah you're allowed to say things like
that
so what do we do about stuff like this
like if they really you know because
people do buy it you know what I mean
they get some crock to go on TV and say
this yeah I find this all the time right
in all these studies they can get anyone
to say anything yeah I have a
fascination with what I like to call my
Stipe and they use it in articles and
they use it on television when there's
this disclaimer and you can't read it
right smallest thing possible right and
I feel like they say well there's a
disclaimer or they have those special
ads and magazines that are supposed to
look like real articles yeah they know
that people aren't paying attention to
the fine print right so they literally
will show you an article on one side and
then the back is all of the horrible
[ __ ] that it does to you right or it'll
be in yeah and in tiny little print
where you can't read it I mean it's like
the pharmaceutical ads where they're
like see if you know this drug is right
for you it may kill you but see if it's
right for you you can get a boner but
you're gonna commit suicide and you
might choke your wife and vomit and
diarrhea and etcetera etcetera great
boner yeah yeah so I I think that I
think disclaimers are important but I do
think there has to be some more
regulation somewhere along the way where
people are actually forced in some
capacity to pay attention or it's more
obvious of what's going on or I guess
you just have to be smarter which is
what you're gonna say I'm sure people
just starting so is that ultimately is
that what everything comes down to it's
just education right we have to teach
people that when you get information
from coca-cola about how healthy
coca-cola might be that may not be the
best place to be getting your
information you know I was suspicious of
my doctor when he started recommending
coca-cola but when he said camel lights
I really knew he was a bad doctor and he
was taking money from somebody they even
got a sign that they'd recently just
really got revealed that the scientists
from
all the big senators quote from the
Smithsonian Institute yeah it's been on
the take from fossil fuel industries
taking million dollars over just to
produce these studies that say climate
change is happening because of solar
flare right so he's like the one guy
denying he was the one guy he had some
position at the Smithsonian so everybody
like to reference him and it turns out
he's completely on the take and for a
million dollars which is less money than
dr. evil at four in the sixty
are we gonna ever get this so this issue
with sort of corporations funding
education or what poses as education
that's pretty much the most important
issue of our day isn't it as
corporations keep tightening their grip
on politicians well yeah I mean it's
certainly important to be a good
consumer and not just in product but in
news and information I mean I tell
people that all the time when we talk
about what's out there online they say
how do you know if something's a viable
source you have to do your research you
don't have to look and if I read
something that sounds like a bunch of
baloney I'm gonna go out and find out
whether or not it's true on my own yeah
but I know a lot of people are very lazy
when it comes to information they read
online and they just fold it along or
pass it on without any sort of
verification you just have to be
responsible for your own information I
think actually that's the perfect ending
to this one be responsible that's why we
always put the articles in the
descriptions right there we give you a
little bit information you guys can run
with it Jimmy bring it home here I think
no just you got a question everything
you see on Facebook Abraham Lincoln said
that